Evil Geniuses have climbed to the very
top of the valorant world winning
champions less than three weeks ago now
according to a new report they won't be
resigning that roster unless the players
agree to significant pay cuts the
situation seems absurd so what's really
going on here
[Music]
weeks ago eg-1 Valor Champions 2023 the
team and its players were on top of the
world David one of the other side Ethans
found mine freak is down to two they
what
[Applause]
world champions
but this week well that all seems like a
distant memory on Monday evening
reporter Max Katz tweeted that according
to his sources EG would only resign
their Championship winning roster if the
players agreed to a significant pay cut
EG has allowed the roster to explore
their options after that report there
was a sequence of vague tweets by the
roster about how winning wasn't valued
anymore even com's dad got in on it we
reached out for comment to both Riot
games and Evil Geniuses but didn't
receive a response by time of recording
on Tuesday afternoon EG Valor player com
went live and in a now deleted live
stream explained that he felt like his
experience with the org left him feeling
like he was disrespected I literally
just wanted to play with my brothers I
was willing to give up so much to play
with my brothers and now I don't have
the opportunity so we went through so
much
to just not even get the respect we
deserved and listen lots of other
Esports personalities got in on this
thing on Tuesday Morning deserto
journalist Jacob Hale tweeted that no
one should be surprised that
organizations are trying to push
salaries down look the specific numbers
became a matter of discussion But
ultimately I don't think they matter
that much as Bryce Bloom pointed out in
this Twitter thread if they're
outstripping the ability to bring in
money that just can't happen long term
so I'm gonna focus on a different
question what does this actually mean
well for one it shows a startling lack
of power for these players to advocate
for themselves at the highest level of
competitive Valor I mean you'd think
winning a championship would entitle you
to some amount of job security but it
kind of seems like that's not really the
case here and listen the orgs that hold
these franchise spots they have a lot of
power they are essentially Gatekeepers
to the highest levels of competition in
a given tolerant region a tweet from
exalt seems to exemplify this attitude
if you want to play in franchising well
there are only so many options some
people alluded to this power imbalance
others accused actions like these a
threatening to ruin valorin if the
reports are accurate then Evil Geniuses
are seemingly more concerned with
cutting costs than well most other
things and salaries are unfortunately a
natural place for corporate eyes to
fixate the org CEO Nicola Point Jamison
recently stepped down from her position
she spoke with digiday's Alexander Lee
and when asked if the orgs LCS slot was
up for sale she kind of dodged the
question more than anything else Evil
Geniuses despite facing several
controversies also arguably did achieve
a lot of their goals in terms of
reaching new fans in new games maybe
they view this tumultuous time as a
moment to cut back and ride it out in
the games where they found fans still
it's hard to stomach the symbolism of a
championship winning Foster getting
railroaded because their employer
controls their access to top level
competition if that's what's happening
here now these franchising Partners were
chosen by Riot based on what they called
a competitive process with Financial
reviews and honestly if you go back and
look at the LCS and LEC in the early
days of franchising they had this same
stated long-term Focus I guess you need
those partner teams to be able to
survive too and more generally we're
still feeling the effects of the general
Esports downturn the last thing we need
to talk about here Evil Geniuses are
looking to cut costs even in their
Championship winning roster so what does
that say about the rest of the landscape
so with very few exceptions all of your
favorite Esports orgs are still riding
the high of that venture capital
investment all while trying desperately
to find ways to make money and paying
salaries of players that are probably
deservedly very high to Keys points
salaries are again something you can
expect to see company's Target because
for the most part they've gone up that's
a good thing mind you if we want the
best possible competition we need
players to be able to make a living from
it and we need to be able to protect
those players if revenue is looking
Bleak salaries will feel the sting at
some point I can't say that it's
necessarily fair in this case because I
don't have access to all the numbers
behind the scenes and even then fairness
might be a subjective sort of thing but
what I can say is that given everything
that's happening I'm not sure this would
be entirely unexpected that it happened
in exactly this way at this moment is
still surprising and perhaps points to
the urgency that some of these teams are
experiencing could we see riots step in
and do something directly frankly that's
pretty hard for me to imagine but at the
same time it's hard to deny that this
vertigo inducing headline looks pretty
bad for the lead Riot already risked a
lot when they implemented the changes
that led to the disruption of the start
of the LCS season now in this case it
seems like they're in action may be
viewed as taking the side of the
companies over the players at the end of
the day only time will tell
I'm just being honest I'm getting a PSL
after this the PSL goes hard this year
if you don't like the PSL probably won't
like it still but man I'm just feeling
it I was walking home crisp air
Cool Breeze thinking man gonna cozy up
in the basement with a PSL
not sponsored by them they go hard this
year though I don't know I just gotta
have one